- What's up, Believe Nation?
Greetings from London, England.
It's Evan.
My one word is believe
and I believe in people,
more than they believe in themselves.
And I want some of that to rub off on you
so you can go off and do amazing things
to change the planet.
In this video I'm doing a highlight reel.
The best of videos from
different entrepreneur channels.
These are friends of mine.
These are people who are
also creating great content
to help you guys as entrepreneurs.
Maybe you've seen their channels,
maybe you've never heard of them before.
This is my favorites from the past month
that they've put out.
And if you want to check
them out fully you can
go to look at the links
in the description below.
Enjoy guys.
(light music)
- And I need you to be very
honest about where you are
in terms of what you tryin to do.
Like where are you?
So for those of you who like
I want to be a millionaire
I just need you to really think through
where are you financially?
In terms of financially
literacy where are you.
In terms of financial
discipline where are you.
In your past where are you.
Do you spend money you don't have?
I heard somebody say this the other day.
I thought it was funny.
Somebody was talking about-
I'm talking about mentality,
I need you all to heard me.
Can you lift your own weight.
Can you lift your own weight?
Somebody was saying like
yo, I don't you know why
you all on the phone
all proud of that fact
that you can change you own oil.
Why would you want to
change your oil anyway
if that's not your job?
Somebody was like well I save $140.
He like save $140?
But what if you make $250 an hour?
Hear what I'm saying.
Why would you change
your own oil to save $140
when it took you three hours to do it?
And somebody like yo so
you sayin you always-
I said look, let me jump in.
I ain't tryin to be
disrespectful, but first of all
I didn't go to school to change oil.
That ain't my job.
That's somebody else job.
Let my man do his job.
Somebody else said that
when he change your oil
because he went to school.
There's some other stuff
under the engine that he see
that you don't see when
you're changing your oil.
So while you saved $140,
you missed something else
that he would have helped
catch so that the life
of your car-
(clap)
- so you changed your
oil but you didn't notice
the three or four other
things that was missing.
I said look, let's not
talk about you saving $140.
Here is the challenge.
You can't pull your own weight.
The challenge is you
shouldn't have a car that cost
you $140 to change the oil
when you ain't got $140
to change the oil.
(applause)
- You shouldn't have that
car in the first place.
Why do you have a vehicle
that the oil cost $140
and you can't afford it.
Why would you buy something
that you got to change
the oil, that's not your job.
And you know why you doin it?
Because it's no longer a car to you,
now it's a status symbol.
And so we dealin with something deeper.
You can't hold your own weight.
You bought something you can't afford.
Why?
The deeper issue is because
you got a self esteem problem.
And so you got short cut
so you drive a car to make
it look like you somewhere
you are, but when you actually
there you ain't got to
have a car that look like
you there cus you there.
No, hear what I just said.
When you're there you don't
have to look like you there
cus you there.
But when you not there you
can't pick your own weight up.
You have to do stuff and
now you done messed up
your whole credit because you got a car
so that people can think
you somewhere that you not.
You've destroyed you whole future.
Now if you could hold
your own weight you could
drive around in a Ford Fusion
and I'm talkin about comfortable-
like a Range Rover.
You getting out of that
joint like a Range Rover.
You getting out the Ford Fusion like what-
like you in the 745Li like what.
Why?
Because you ready.
Are you hearin me, you ready.
(light music)
- [Jocko] People look for the short cut.
The hack.
The short cut is a lie.
The hack doesn't get you there.
There is no easy way
there is only discipline.
You can't control other people.
There only person you can control is you.
You have control over your mind.
Weakness.
I'm nothing but weakness.
I get emotional over stupid things.
I eat the wrong foods.
I don't sleep enough.
I procrastinate,
I waste time.
I care too much about stupid things
and not enough about important things.
In all those ways I am weak.
But-
I don't accept that.
(light music)
- Here's something that's
important to relay to children.
That you are not your accomplishments.
You are you.
And the only way that you
are going to get better
at accomplishing things
is to be 100% honest
about the amount of effect you put in
and what the actual
result of that effort is.
Whether it's a failure or a success
that does not define you.
That defines your participation
in this particular activity.
It is not you.
You are an individual
that will hopefully learn
from all of your endeavors.
You're never going to learn
if you lie to yourself.
Never going to learn if somebody
makes this nobody scores
a point and there are no
winners and are no losers
and everybody's amazing.
That's not good.
- [Man] That's a good voice by the way.
- It's not good because there's
going to be people out there
that are driven and psychotic.
And they're going to get ahead.
There's people that are task oriented
and goal oriented and they
have an idea ahead of them.
Going to try to figure out
how to make this happen.
They have a goal, they want to reach it.
And if you're competing with that person,
in any form of life, and
they're not burdened down
by the bull that we
give so many kids today.
They're going to have a massive advantage.
And this idea that this
kid that's been coddled
and treated like he's
always going to be a winner
then some how our another
they're going to be happier
is crazy.
(light music)
- You know, I think about
the business as the horse
and I think of the CEO as the jockey.
I always, if it's 50/50
lean toward the person
because some of the biggest business-
Nintendo-
started as a playing card company.
And it was the entrepreneurs
that ran that business
that kept changing the business.
You know, when I started Vayner Media
I didn't think it would
be what it is today.
I never thought it would
I thought is was going to
be something different.
So great entrepreneurship
is not being romantic
about what you started to
do, it's about adjusting
to the reality of what
your business has to do.
I never have invested-
that's not true.
There have been times when
I have become so infatuated
with the person that
I met, that I invested
even though I didn't
believe in their idea.
Because I wanted to build
a relationship with them
and I thought to myself even
if I lose this 25 or $50,000
in the second of third
business that she or he builds,
she'll be successful.
And I'll be there to be a part of it.
Far more often I have
to believe in your idea
and believe that you have the stomach.
My biggest fear with your
generation of entrepreneurship
is that entrepreneurship is now cool.
And that you're doing it because
of either money or coolness
not because you can't breath without it.
And I'm looking for
entrepreneurs that can't breathe-
if you think in your mind
right now, it'll be really
cool to try a business.
But if it doesn't work
I'll go into banking,
I don't want to invest in you.
(light music)
- I think it's powerful
because I think most people
aren't willing to reinvent.
You were doing the internet
marketing spammy thing
for a little bit.
- [Man] Yeah.
- If you kept doing that you would have
probably dropped off too.
- [Man] Yeah.
- But you found a way to
reinvent with blogging.
- [Man] Yeah.
- And you stuck with
that until you realized
oh let me do the next stage.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Right.
I think that's always important.
I was kind of in a similar spot.
I was starting out in blogging,
I was teaching LinkedIn.
- Yeah.
- And I was like ah, it's kind of dying
and blogging with the
courses and I was like
I felt like podcasting
was going to come around.
Hopefully, you know.
- You're in the right space now, man.
(laughs)
- It was like two years before
it starting getting big.
When serial came out and
everyone else started to do them.
I was like thank goodness I started early.
It's almost like now there
is over half a million
podcasts at least.
So it's like what's the next reinvention.
- [Man] Yeah.
- I'm always looking for
the next reinvention.
(light music)
- Never get your financial
advice from a millionaire.
Stop thinking like a middle class loser.
Folks, the middle class
is a losing situation.
I know people hate this
message, it is not popular.
I'm going to keep telling
you until you finally
come around to what I know.
The middle class is based on scarcity.
Million dollars, a million dollars today
is the new middle class.
Let's say you can't make any
money for the next 30 years.
Let's just assume because
you said a million dollars
is a bunch of money.
Not if you don't have
more money coming in.
So if I stop the drip coming
in, if I stop the income.
Because the millionaire
next door said income is not
the way to get rich.
That's not true.
Income is the way to stay rich.
You can't get rich without
income and you can't stay
rich without income.
The problem with money is time.
So if you have a million
dollars and you only have
one day left to live, too rich.
You understand what I'm saying?
Money is basically a measurement of time.
Think big.
Do not get you're advice
from little thinkers.
Why would you be a millionaire
when you could be a hundred million.
Do the math.
What's the real number?
Who wants one?
Of anything?
The number one is a weak number.
It's the zeros that are powerful.
Get you a bunch of zeros and
then add any number to them.
(light music)
- I was a fool in my twenties.
I had such low self
esteem and I was trying
to find my way.
Just as all 20 year olds are.
How old are you?
- I'm going to be 20.
- [Oprah] You're going to be 20?
- Yeah.
- [Oprah] You're not even 20?
- No, not yet.
(laughs)
- Okay so this is the thing.
I would say to experience
the 20s as an adventure
in learning about yourself.
It really is the opportunity
where you get to discover
who you are, what you want to do.
Where you passion lies.
You're supposed to do things, figure out
uh this doesn't really feel
like where I'm supposed
to be in my life and then move on.
Listening to your instincts
is really key in your 20s
so that you don't mess yourself up.
Really, truly.
I did all my awful stuff.
Including drugs and wrong
men and holding onto bumpers.
And don't leave me.
It's about discovering
who you are and not giving
over your power to someone else
and believing that anybody
else defines your life.
(light music)
- [Julian] How can I learn to feel good
about the work that I create?
- Ahhh, if I could answer
this definitively I would
be a very wealthy man.
Because I would of
smoothed out a lot of pain
for a lot of people over centuries.
Let me as you a follow up question here.
Presumably you're saying
like you make something
and then a little bit later you look at it
and you like oh my god
what was I thinking?
Is that a common theme?
- [Julian] Yeah, a lot
of times, for me at least
it happens in the
process of a project too.
- Got it.
I got two directions I want to take this.
First of all, there's
this arc of a project
like this is a great idea.
And then the next step is I'm
not quite so sure about this.
The next one is oh my god
this great idea sucks.
And then it's I suck.
And then you keep putting
effort in and then you're like
wait a minute I can see the
light at the end of the tunnel
everything is going to be okay.
Oh my god, I'm okay and this
piece of work is pretty good.
And notice it's not like
if it does turn out
good, then you're like,
not just pretty good.
Then oh my god this is awesome,
I'm so glad I pushed through.
On each project level,
and I think James Victorie
has talked a lot about this.
He's a famous designer,
I don't know if you know
him or not.
There's this, oh, Austin Kleon,
the guy who wrote Show Your Work.
And what else did he write?
And Steal Like an Artist.
Those are two really great books
if you haven't checked that out.
But he's got a really funny
graph that sort of covers
this emotional arc that
creators go through
on any individual project.
So I want you to check out
Austin and I think I'm kind of
paraphrasing a little, that journey.
So while you're in the process
that is part of the process.
And I would also say that if
you don't get into something
where you're annoyed at the
details and they're frustrating
and painful then you really
haven't gotten into it.
If you're just sort of
glossing on the surface,
you're bouncing across the
surface then you're probably
not getting into it enough to
make something that's amazing.
I would say try and get used
to that arc on every project.
I don't think it ever goes away
if you're putting as much
effort into it as you should.
That's one thing that I want
you to pay attention to.
Again, I gave you a
couple resources there.
(light music)
- In this video, of course
yes, you're going to learn
how to win an argument but
you're also going to learn
how to get what it is
that you actually want
from the argument.
You're going to learn
how to make it so that
the relationship is strengthened after it
and not ruined even if you do
wind up getting what you want.
The first thing is this.
We want to redefine what winning means.
Because sadly, to many of
us, what winning an arguemnt
means is the other guy losing.
We want them to admit
their opinion in wrong.
We want the people who are
around who are watching us
argue to say you have a
really good point, man.
They're out of their mind.
But the truth is, say
you're arguing about chores.
And you want the other
person to do more chores.
And everybody at the
end says you were right,
you won, they lost.
Well guess what, that
doesn't feel very good, one.
And two, they're still not
doing what you want them to.
Which is to help out ore around the house.
So redefine what a win is.
What is it that you
actually want to change
from this discussion?
And that'll shift it from
an argument to a discussion.
So if you want the person to do chores,
okay start there.
If you're in a legal or a
business setting and you want
more money, more favorable
contract terms, start there.
Forget sticking it to them
or teaching them a lesson or
showing how silly they are.
When those are your
motivators, everybody loses.
But when you focus on
the things that you want
you are much more likely
to communicate in a way
that gets them.
(light music)
- A poor man with
confidence is unstoppable.
I love that quote, I love the message.
And I agree.
The next question that
becomes is well how do you get
that confidence if you're
in a bad environment,
if you're poor, if you don't
have great people around you
how do get that confidence?
And some people may be
born with it, I don't know.
For me it was much more about
changing my environment.
So I got confidence, some
of it from my parents
believe came from them.
They always told me I was
Evan Castreeli Carmichael
I could do whatever I
wanted and that gave me
a sense of confidence.
But if I looked then into
my entrepreneurial career
a lot of if came from my
habits and what I was reading
and now later into the videos.
By surrounding myself with
people that are confident,
that are doing big things.
Not necessarily in my actual
life, you know I don't have
a ton of super successful,
super confident friends
that I hang around with.
It's much more from aspirational mentors.
And I created the
YouTube channel, in part,
selfishly for myself.
The top ten rules selfishly for myself.
To be around greatness,
to be around success
on a regular basis.
And you can do that for yourself as well.
If you want to develop confidence
it may come by watching videos
on seven ways to get more
confidence or reading books
on how to be more confident.
Kind of those tactical how tos.
But I think a lot of it also comes
from just the environment.
Just from osmosis.
Just by being around confident people.
And some of that wears off on you.
It's why I started the Mentor Me series.
Let's hang around people who
have done a lot more than
us and some of their
mindsets and their beliefs
and the way that they think about things
seeps into us to help us become
the best version of ourselves.
Not to be the next Elon Musk
or Steve Jobs or whoever
but a more confident better
version of ourselves.
And there's a point
where it really struck me
where I was driving with
my father in the car
and I just signed a
deal with Stephen Kelly
who's the CEO of Sage and
he runs multi-billion dollar
company with 10-15,000 employees.
And we're both doing this Q&A.
We're answering questions,
I'm hosting the show.
We get a question from an entrepreneur,
he answers it, I answer it.
My dad asked me, how do
you get the confidence
to be on par with Stephen Kelly?
That you're his equal, that
you're answering questions
along side him?
It wasn't in a you suck kind
of tone, it was in a general
admiration, like where did that come from?
Like that's amazing in a supportive way.
And I thought about it and
it's really from the videos.
It's really from all this
work because I'm hanging
around Elon Musk and
Kanye West and Snoop Dogg
and Martha Stewart and all
of these successful people
whether they're athletes or
musicians or entrepreneurs.
I'm around that constantly.
And so seeing people being
confident and going off
and doing great things
makes me be more confident.
And so by hanging around
greatness more you unleash
a little bit more greatness
inside of yourself as well.
And the more you do that and
the more consistent you are
with that, then the more
is going to come out.
So I agree that a poor
man with confidence will
be unstoppable, the question
becomes how will you get
that confidence and if
you weren't born with it
I think that's okay.
I think there's so much that
you can do by changing your
habits, by changing your environment,
by surrounding yourself
with maybe not people,
like you may not have people around you.
But by resources,
information, videos, guides
of confident, successful people.
That will unleash that
inner boldness in you
to go off and do amazing things.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know which
one was your favorite,
which clip you learned
the most from that you're
going to apply immediately
somehow to your life or to your business.
Leave it there in the comments below.
Thank you again.
We believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you one word is.
Much love, guys, from London.
See you soon.